you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news live from cop 26 in glasgow
coming up get serious now or it'll be
too late for our children boris
johnson's hard-hitting message as the
summit opens the calls from politicians
and activists alike
it's one minute to midnight on that
doomsday clock and we need
to act now
indigenous peoples are in the front line
of the climate emergence and we must be
at the center of the decisions having
here
but is the world listening the indian
prime minister narendra modi says his
country will take half a century to
achieve net zero
after boris johnson put cop's chances of
success at six out of ten i ask his
predecessor theresa may for her verdict
also we report from madagascar in the
indian ocean a nation likely to be
declared the first to suffer from a
climate change famine
[Music]
and i'm live in the amazon a part of the
planet so crucial to its very well-being
and where the spread of the rainforest
biggest city has brought pollution to
its rivers
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show live for the next
fortnight from the very heart of the cop
26 summit in glasgow it's the largest
conference ever seen in the uk and
arguably the most crucial well the
opening ceremonies host boris johnson
said the world was strapped to a
doomsday device just one minute from
midnight while the u.n secretary general
called on the world to stop treating
nature like a toilet
well this evening a commitment from
india one of the world's biggest
polluters whose prime minister pledged
to reach net zero by 2070 but that's a
decade later than china and russia and
20 years later than the summit's target
date
our political editor beth rigby has this
evening's first report
cop 26 in glasgow there's no
underestimating the scale of this
climate summit but what's at stake
greater still and the negotiations
difficult
the host greeting dozens of world
leaders
[Music]
and hoping big polluters like president
modi of india will finally embrace the
need to act
working in tandem with old reliable
allies no longer enough
the pm with a pointed warning if glasgow
fails it all fails
it's possible that there's only one
civilization in the milky way galaxy
the responsibility weighs heavily on
these leaders the world's in their hands
and he knows that look at his face
welcome to cop
welcome to glasgow
and to scotland
whose most globally famous fictional son
is almost certainly a man
called james bond
who generally comes to the climax of his
highly lucrative films strapped to a
doomsday device
we are in roughly the same position my
fellow global leaders
as james bond
today
except
that the tragedy is
this is not
a movie
and the doomsday device is real
it's one minute to midnight on that
doomsday clock and we need
to act now
if we don't get serious
about climate change today
it will be too late for our children to
do so tomorrow
decisions made here in the next two
weeks will decide the future for
generations to come on this the
president of the european commission
telling me she agrees with the pm from
sky news can i just ask you one quick
question
how much is at stake here and how
confident are you that we can make real
progress on climate change
this is a moment of truth and we really
have to step up
it was good that g20 came up with a
united position of 1.5 degrees celsius
we want to reach and the climate finance
because the g20 are 80 percent of the
emitters worldwide but now we have to
get concrete because action has to
happen now in this decade and therefore
we need a clear plan a road map by every
country that is contributing to cop 26
how they want to reach their goals in
2013.
and this leader clear what failure means
our world my friends
stands
at a fork in the road
one no less significant
than when the united nations was formed
in 1945
but then
the majority of our countries here did
not exist
we exist now the difference is we want
to exist a hundred years from now
and if
our existence is to mean anything
then we must act in the interests of all
of our people
not only is this a gigantic summit it's
also a giant pressure pot in which the
world's biggest polluters come face to
face with the country's dealing with the
consequences whose very existence is
threatened by global warming the leaders
who are here hope that in the next two
weeks they can agree concrete actions to
truly begin to tackle climate change but
they need russia brazil and china to
step up and those leaders aren't here
president modi of india has at least
turned up but he's not stepped up enough
the world's third biggest emitter
committing to net zero but not until
2017.
worst
by 2017
2070
india will achieve the target
of net zero emissions
not a good start this summer stuttering
just as it begins i don't i don't think
failure is an option you know i don't
think we can ever declare this uh a
failure we can't have like in copenhagen
in 2009 the world was seen to have
completely failed and it meant kind of
years of hangover we can't have that
happen again so whatever happens after
glasgow we've got to pick ourselves up
but it requires leaders to come here not
with their pre-prepared plans but to
negotiate on the basis of the science
not negotiate with the science but
negotiate with each other on the basis
of the science
but at least the world's biggest player
is on the pitch and doing its bit
will we seize the enormous opportunity
before us
we all really condemn future generations
to suffer
this
is the decade that will determine the
answer the united states will be able to
meet the ambitious target i said
the leaders summit and climate back in
april reducing u.s emissions
by 50 to 52 percent below
2005
levels by 2030.
we'll demonstrate to the world the
united states is not only back at the
table but hopefully leading by the
power of our example
in glasgow rolling out the royal red
carpet not just for france but the whole
of the world but with china absent and
india falling short team world
struggling beth rigby sky news glasgow
well this in a nutshell is what this
summit is all about an attempt to keep
global warming below 1.5 degrees celsius
since pre-industrial times
so you can see the earth is already
heated up by 1.2 more than
1.23 degrees and the best way of keeping
that number down is to have more of our
energy coming from nuclear power and
renewables that's wind solar and hydro
power and less from gas and coal and you
can see over here how great britain's
power mix is looking right now with 9
coal and there's the other fossil fuel
gas that we're reliant on well our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter has been speaking to
delegates here in glasgow about their
proposals to keep 1.5 alive
as thousands gather from all over the
world
cop 26 is a complicated and frenetic
place
some world leaders still feeling hopeful
mildly optimistic mildly optimistic
as michael thatcher would say cautiously
optimistic others feeling the pressure
we have to deliver
no option and no there's not an option
whatever the approach they all have a
long list of challenges hanging over
their heads
must revisit their national climate
plans and policies
not every five years
every year
every moment until keeping to 1.5
degrees is assured until subsidies to
fossil fuels end
until there is a price on carbon
until coal is phased out
away from the big stage is where it all
happens
this is where the real work of cop26
takes place negotiators behind closed
doors trying to hammer out differences
and find common ground but that's a
really tough task when everybody has
different priorities
for some it's about trees
we hope that we can reach an agreement
of zero deforestation by 2030. in our
case we've made that commitment and not
sooner and something that is very
important we have committed that before
the august next year we'll have 30
percent of the colombian land declared
as a protected area and that's a crucial
issue for you yeah it's it's a priority
for me for others
cash commitments you know the financial
commitment should be the relatively easy
one for developed rich developed
countries to deliver the fact that it
hasn't been met yet is pretty shameful a
crucial issue is finance in all aspects
of finance and very importantly what the
private financial sector is doing
and is it going to step up and that's
one of the key objectives of the prime
minister
and for others the detail of
understanding carbon emission reduction
how do we measure how do we report
emissions so that we can do it
transparent and
technical detail but very important also
also yes but they are important
every single one of these issues has
undone previous cops and may do so again
this time the clash of competing
national interests overriding the needs
of the collective whole
but under this intense spotlight these
leaders must navigate to consensus
the planet depends on it
hannah thomas peter sky news at cop 26
in glasgow
the u.n has warned that madagascar is on
the brink of the world's first climate
change famine
well the indian ocean island has been
experiencing its worst drought in 40
years with extreme weather patterns
including cyclones high winds and dust
storms our special correspondent alex
crawford is in ambongo in the south of
the island
that huge swathe of sand that you can
see was the manumova river it's dry all
the way along here and again for miles
round the corner
the drought here has been so prolonged
in parts of the country they haven't
seen proper rainfall for 40 years
they're talking about many of the
malagasy are saying it's the worst
period they've ever been through they're
having to dig holes just to try to get
access to the water table so they can
have water to cook to clean
to drink and this is a country which
basically gets around on this carts not
many of them in comparison to the
population have access to cars they
don't even have access to electricity
only about 15 percent
of the country have access to
electricity so they're one of the lowest
emitters of carbon
emissions in the world and yet they are
the country which is
really feeling the most impact with the
un declaring that parts of the country
are on the brink of tipping into famine
most of the country about 80 percent of
them go to bed hungry every night
only earning about two dollars a day and
they are desperate for change you can
see the wind and hear how windy it is
they're being prone to more and more of
these extreme weathers these dust storms
which uh can whip up in and cause a lot
of damage are called as teominas and
they're more and more prevalent they
have more and more cyclones every year
they have extreme periods of of dryness
this is meant to be the rainy season
when they're meant to have their
substantial rainfall the dry season
doesn't begin for another three months
so the people here are desperate and
crying out for change on a global scale
we are alex crawford there in madagascar
what's happening here in the amazon well
you may have seen yesterday we flew over
this great rainforest to see how the
behavior of man is directly impacting
climate change here particularly as
regards the illegal logging that is
taking place over vast areas of uh the
forest but we've also witnessed how
industry and unregulated housing
settlements uh many of the people are
moving into the desperately poor and
have nowhere else to go how those
settlements are eating into the rain
forest and not only is it causing many
more trees to be lost but the levels of
pollution here are slowly killing the
dozens of small rivers crossing uh the
city of manaus around 148 of them and
this is what we found when we went out
this is a tributary that feeds the grand
rivers that sustain the amazon forest
just look at these pictures
and think about that
because they are not only destroying
trees here they're poisoning rivers too
for joe farah a local campaigning to
save the waterways of manaus it is
heartbreaking you'll not see it
it's just terrible i was born here i
used to swim in this river he told me
it's not only what you see here that's
so depressing it's what you smell it's
industrial waste chemicals and human
sewage flowing through here
this is what man is doing to one of the
greatest and most important rainforests
in the world
much of the pollution is from
uncontrolled housing settlements this
entire area was rainforest just 20 years
ago
most of the 148 small rivers that cross
the city are little more than channels
of human waste
they are dying
on their banks i found the desperately
poor trying to exist amid hopelessness
and disease
understandably for people like mother
and daughter rosa and gaisa it is daily
survival they care about not the fate of
the rainforest or fears of climate
change
all i know is every day here is worse
because the government won't help us
says rosa
marcus castro a professor of urban
geography here says it's too easy to
blame the poor problem
the problem here is there is such
inequality and no proper planning he
says so they have no choice
he thinks rather look to a government
that day by day is allowing development
to eat into the rainforest
river campaigner joe farah is not
prepared to let the rivers here die in
the forest on the edge of the city he
and his team are planting new trees on
the banks of a river he's determined to
preserve my first tree here
regeneration and regrowth that is badly
needed here
and below them pure water running as it
should do
and i've got to say when you travel
around manaus on the outskirts of manaus
it really is notable how much
unregulated and uncontrolled development
is taking place and the big question of
course is when will it all
stop
for now from the amazon that is about
all let's go back to anna in glasgow
mark thanks very much indeed
theresa may was prime minister when her
then foreign secretary boris johnson
seized on the chance for the uk to host
cop 26 a summit that was originally due
to take place in italy well mrs may is
here in glasgow this week and i spoke to
her today in her only television
interview here at cop
and asked whether she rates the chances
of success higher or lower than the 6
out of 10 that mr johnson has touted
i'm confident that there will be success
here at cop26 if you think back to paris
and the paris accord that actually came
together at the last moment but what
matters about cop 26 is it's not a sort
of end point uh what matters is we get
momentum for action coming out of it and
i'm sure that's what we're going to get
when you voted against the government's
foreign aid cards you said then that the
government had broken its promise to the
poorest people of the world
so do you think that developing nations
can trust the uk leadership on climate
action and could that ultimately be a
barrier to success at cop26 i think what
everybody's here about is what we're
going to do about climate change what
the uk has done has shown that important
leadership in being the first major
country to set that net zero target of
2050 and that has been leading the way
and now boris and the government have
published the net zero strategy showing
how we actually get there and that's
what we want coming out of cop26
and you can see more of my conversation
with theresa may after this program on
sky news tonight so do stay tuned for
that
now let's talk about what we've heard
today with rachel kite who is dean of
the fletcher school at tufts university
and former special representative of the
un secretary general for sustainable
energy for all and kave gillampur vice
president for international strategies
at the center for climate and energy
solutions welcome to both of you
so what a day the day one proper of
cop26 carvey boris johnson has talked
about the risk of serious failure at
this summit as a former negotiator both
of you former negotiators what's your
feeling are you feeling optimistic as
cop gets underway well i think the good
news is that yesterday when the former
negotiations started they got off to a
smooth start which is a very good sign
and actually quite unusual there's
usually procedural problems at the
beginning but all the formal agendas for
the meetings were adopted without
problems and i think that bodes well
that negotiators from around the world
have come to be constructive and try to
find a deal so i think the first hurdle
was passed with success yesterday that's
very interesting i know you've been in
meetings today rachel so what are you
picking up what's the mood that you're
sensing well we've seen a
lifting of ambition by india we saw a
very strong speech by the secretary
general saying that he wants everybody
to run within the guard rails and make
sure that all of these promises actually
come true i've been in meetings with the
private sector who are coming and
talking about mobilizing finance some of
the extraordinary innovation the
partnerships that they're forming so you
get this feeling that there's actually a
lot going on and of course you can feel
the pressure from the street and
actually the pressure from the river as
well so you sound quite positive do you
think that we will get to the end of
this and say that cop has been a success
well i think that it's the gap between
uh instrumenting policy if you're a
government and then what the private
sector civil society and everybody else
thinks we can do if we can close that
gap so that governments leave here
believing that they can do more that
they can go faster then today was a good
day in terms of setting that direction
well yes and and that's why this cop is
so interesting isn't it in paris there
was a very binary issue either you got a
deal or you didn't get a deal this time
it's all about how much momentum is
there to keep global warming capped at
1.5 it's going to be quite hard to
measure success isn't it i think so i
mean i think the important thing to
remember is that the paris agreement was
never set up to solve the problem in one
go and it has a cycle to raise ambition
over time and with each cop that
ambition is being raised as rachel said
we saw india step up today brazil the us
has set out its long-term strategy so
whereas in paris we were heading for
four degrees we're heading now for
2.7 or less so it seems to be working
and success may not be known for some
time after this i'm so interested that
both of you have said that it's good
news that india has set out its target
and yet there will be some that will say
but they've said they'll reach net zero
by 2070 which is 20 years after the
target date of this summit and 10 years
behind the likes of of china and russia
so why do you feel this is good news
well because i think that most countries
are going to
over deliver against their promises
because as technology improves as we
understand how better to do this as the
global economy moves so i think that the
hedging of the bets you see in these
kinds of promises might fade away but
also remember that the 2050 target the
1.5 is for the global economy and it was
always understood that some developing
countries would take longer than others
the big stumbling block potentially here
is finance
biden's got a bigger promise that he's
made he's got a plan but the us is far
behind on finance so tomorrow is going
to be a critical day when we see whether
or not there's any money on the table
well yes finance so important and i know
that you've represented the marshall
islands haven't you one of those nations
that risks going underwater because of
climate change
countries like that do they feel they
have a voice do they feel they're being
listened to when they say we still
haven't got our 100 billion dollars we
were promised back in 2009 it was due by
last year we're told we may not get it
for another three years how how how do
they feel could this be a stumbling
block it could be a stumbling block
and not only is there the issue of the
hundred billion on the table at this cop
we also have to decide what happens in
the long term after 2025
and it's not only about the hundred
billion it's really about shifting the
trillions is the phrase how do you align
the global economy
with the net zero target so how does the
financial sector businesses and the
whole global economy align so it's
actually much it's much bigger issue
than 100 billion but that's an important
symbol of trust well yes and so we're
going to listen out for for the issue of
climate finance through the week i mean
mark carney is is working behind the
scenes himself do you think we'll get
some good news on that or not what's
your instinct yeah so mark is talking
about 130 trillion dollars of money and
assets under management committed to net
zero i think that the civil society is
concerned that some of the fine print
there would allow banks that are still
financing coal to be in the club but i
think the point is get them in talking
and then work with them to again ratchet
up their ambition as they learn how to
do this but i think the difference
between now and paris was in paris we
thought that we had a little bit more
time the international energy agencies
report that came out two to three weeks
ago basically said there should be no
more finance going into any new oil gas
and coal and i think that's the cut off
so civil society will say we want to see
that cut off the finance sector will say
give us time and that's the that's the
process oh it's going to be fascinating
all those meetings down those corridors
come back and tell us how they're going
won't you but we must leave it now uh
rachel kite and carve input thanks very
much indeed thank you thank you
and don't forget that you can listen to
a new climate cast every day from cop 26
wherever you find your podcasts and uh
you may well already be watching this on
our pop-up channel but if you're not you
can find uninterrupted coverage from
cop26 that's between 9am and 7pm on
channel 525 all week